okay we're here back and now we're the
questions okay Jonathan alter do you
agree with the Democrats decision to
keep their primary debates off Fox News
no I agree that you need to hunt where
the Ducks are right but you know people
don't know that four years ago the RNC
cancelled the NBC News Republican debate
because they didn't like the way the
CNBC debate had gone earlier so this
idea that some have something horrible
has been done by Tom Perez the
Democratic Party Chairman is not true
and they actually haven't had a Fox
debate in the Democratic Party since
2004 so this it's not like this is
something they do every year and are
cancelling now but you have to take
every opportunity yes voters yeah all
right they got the votes on MSNBC beats
into the wrong narrative anyway so just
put it right
Matt Shannon said early if you want to
play get in the game and play and you
can reach Wisconsin without even going
there right Michael is there anyone in
the Republican Party who can mount a
credible primary challenge to Donald
Trump a good question there are a number
of folks who are already starting to
look at that certainly governor well
former governor of Massachusetts is
already in the game
my governor of Maryland Larry Hogan who
just won reelection in a blue state
that's outnumbered Republicans
two-to-one has done a good job of
governing is looking at the race and
there's a lot of excitement about his
potentiality he brings something to the
conversation that I think sets up a
perfect contrast between trumpism
or Republican trumpism and traditional
Republican ideas and in governance so I
think that's a that's a conversation we
still need to have internally I have
some real concerns about a lot of the
value sets that we have jettison because
of the cult of personality it has always
bothered me from the very beginning and
and so if we get someone involved in the
narrative that can and re-emerge the the
idea that we still stand for free
markets that we still should not spend
more money than we take in that we
should not burden future generations
with debt and deficits that we should
empower communities to make decisions
for themselves that's a debate I think
inside the Republican Party we should be
ready to have
this should really be what do you want
to achieve through a primary challenge
right because unseating the president is
extremely unlikely so do you want to
move the president in your direction and
in that sense who do you want to run
right and but but again that's if that's
going to be part of a national
conversation that you can take place in
on micro deficits I've noticed at CPAC
this year and I've watched it every year
that there used to be when Obama was
president there was a lot of stuff about
the deficit than dead and this year it
seemed to be good we had Tim Chapman
there from Heritage Foundation we had
senator Perdue from Georgia no the fact
is is this which is both parties
deserved to be horsewhipped over there
profligate spending I mean 22 trillion
dollars in debt someone's gonna
eventually say hey guys you're gonna
have to do something brilliant with the
tax cut a trillion dollars okay I'm
gonna disagree with you about the need
for the tax could I actually think
America was growing less and less
competitive because of our our four
fourth highest corporate tax rate but I
do agree with you on spending let's do
something about spending let's do
something about entitled but no that was
the tax rate it wasn't what they what
they act I met effective but only one
party was the one who crowd Lee wore
this mantle of were the party of fiscal
responsibility that was just him a con
right and I agree our party has been
terrible at this okay and you told
Katherine would agree the last four
years Republicans have been a lot worse
Republican presidents than Democratic
presidents you know Obama and Clinton
brought down the deficit with the
Republican Congress and Clinton's raise
but he oversaw a balanced budget okay
Noah doesn't that lenient sentencing of
Paul Manafort suggests that racial bias
still exists in our judicial system well
it could I know I'm a fan of judicial
discretion or a judicial discretion as
an alternative to mandatory minimums
mandatory minimums are unjust however
the so the notion here that the judicial
system is imperfect because it's just it
was created by the hands of man is
something that I think all of us would
agree there sometimes the judicial
system fails to that's why you have the
power
to save people from from conditions that
are unjust the social justice
prescription the rauzein prescription
john rawls prescription is to create
institutions that are dedicated to
establishing justice by treating
individuals unequally essentially
exacerbating the very condition that is
making the judicial system unjust in the
first place that is the flaw in Rossi
and thought that is the flaw and social
justice thought okay there isn't such a
thing as social justice thought it's
it's something that you've constructed
as a way of well in in theory that
you're reading in the in the Academy but
for most people social justice means
trying to make society better and why do
you need to turn it into some sort of a
caricature because because there is a
caricature agree on the specific cases
so speak out if there is there in the
news every day and people see that
people were asked what what that why
they like Trump the number one thing
they said was he's not politically
correct it's a huge issue and that
doesn't mean he's not also a huge
[ __ ] but that was a breath of fresh
air in a country that was joking and is
joking on political correct rights like
that there is any difference to turn the
idea of social justice into a no neither
Bros or social justice liberals want to
protect people the people we're going
after want to protect feeling I
completely agree there's uncommon really
arguing if there's a need a criminal
justice and we just signed a bill and
you didn't get there by telling people
to sit down shut up and check their
privilege that's right okay
John do you agree with Elizabeth
Warren's plan to break up the tech
companies you know she just came up with
it but I do think that a lot of
antitrust action the way Theodore
Roosevelt and other presidents did is
called for right now we haven't had any
trust in a long time and Louie Brandeis
was right that bigness can sometimes
equal badness and they abuse consumers
when they get too big and I think that
is starting to happen with the tech
companies they should take McKenna close
can't you just hold bigness to be
accountable for what they do because
that's but that's part of the problem
you can break them up and still not
address the underlying problem that's
true that that caused the behavior that
everyone's upset about so instead of
trying to deconstruct something that was
built at the hands in the in the sweat
of someone who took the very risks that
were necessary to create a Google and a
Microsoft etc instead of say well we
it's too big now because we don't know
what to do with it let's break it down
listen look at the underlying issues
that caused the concern that that a lot
of us have relation well guys are
against regulations that's not true and
I think basically consumers should be
able to control their data they should
be able to decide what they do in these
privacy policies and all these platforms
are ridiculously complex and what we're
learning is they just override any box
you check anyway and that and that's
probably a fraud I take matters into my
own hands and just lecture my Alexa
because I know it goes straight to the
top
[Applause]
you